hi so my name is Varun and welcome to
mathematics of animation so um I really
like code pen it's an amazing community
I use it - all the time - to build build
stuff for myself making little
experiments but I probably spend a lot
more time just looking at all the
amazing work there and there's some
truly fascinating animation and
interactive and just just in general
front-end engineering work that showcase
there and one thing that quite often
happens is I look at this work and
wonder how did they do that because I
would really like to know how did they
do that so that I can do that for myself
and the benefit of it being köppen is
you can actually go in and see the code
yourself so I spend a lot of time
looking at some of my favorite pieces up
there and reading the code reading
tutorials and blog posts and one thing
that I discovered was a lot of it came
down to just understanding a little bit
of basic math math and just that little
basic information goes a really long way
that allows you to build some truly
amazing work and this was especially
important for me since I attended do a
lot more reactive animations which are
slightly different to the general
timeline based animations so in a
timeline based animation you have a
timeline you you set your keyframes and
things sort of tween between those
keyframes in reactive animations instead
of having a timeline you're using you're
usually driving that animation to some
sort of events whether that's user
interaction so for example the mouse
cursor moving around a page or gestures
so the middle example there is Google
Chrome on iOS where when you pull down
and you move your thumb around on the
page that's what drives the animation
for that header but also those enemy
those events could come from some other
source so for example a back-end service
so uber for their map for their map they
tend to animate the map based on data
coming from their back-end API and
that's what's driving the animation in
that in that scenario so when you're
working these events it's kind of
important to under
extend what that math is that's driving
these animations so that you can
actually map those events to to these
things that are moving onto the screen
so with that in mind I just wanted to
share a few techniques that I tend to
use a lot in my work and then talk about
the mathematical concepts behind them so
that you can leverage them and build
things for yourself so I'm going to
start with coordinate geometry and when
designers and illustrators when they're
creating their work they tend to think
in shapes or images but when we want to
translate that into something we can
render onto the screen in a web page or
in an application we need to convert
those shapes and images into numbers and
code and one way to do that is through
coordinate geometry and more
specifically the Cartesian coordinate
system this is something you probably
have come across if you've worked with
CSS or HTML or WebGL or even work with
tools such as illustrator or sketch and
in Cartesian code
coordinates the idea is that you locate
points on a on a 2d canvas by finding
how far away they are from the origin so
for example up here the point XY is X
units away from the origin in the X
direction and y units away from the
origin in the Y direction and this is
pretty handy once we can locate these
points we can we can get a whole bunch
of those points join them join them up
together and create shapes on our canvas
right and this is pretty handy this is
the concept that you use in all kinds of
graphics programming whether that's for
the web or for using OpenGL or whatever
right but what if you wanted to create
something a little bit more specific
like this like this illustration in this
case you know that the shapes that
you're building have a very specific you
know has a very specific shape to it
even if you reduce it down to something
like a hexagon if you wanted to draw
this you need to figure out the location
for every single point of this hexagon
so what's the coordinate for that first
vertex then find the coordinate for the
second one the third
and so on and then imagine if you were
animating this every time you move this
hexagon for every for every P frame that
you're creating you need to go and
calculate those vertices every single
time now I don't know about you but that
sounds like a lot of work to me and I
tend to be fairly lazy so is there a
better way to do this or a slightly
simpler way to do this and the answer is
yes there is another coordinate system
out there called the polar coordinate
system which we can leverage to build
shapes such as this and polar
coordinates are fairly related to
Cartesian coordinates but the only
difference is instead of thinking about
points in X and y we start thinking
about them in terms of r and theta where
R is the distance between the origin and
the point that you're trying to locate
and theta is the angle of the direction
of that point so when you draw a line
from that point XY to the origin that
line has an angle from the x axis that's
that's what theta is so so if you know
those two things you can now start to
locate any point in this 2d space and
the nice thing is we can switch back and
forth between the two so if we wanted to
convert something that's based in polar
coordinates into Cartesian coordinates
well X is simply R times cosine of theta
and Y is simply R times sine of theta so
we can switch back and forth between
them and that comes in pretty handy
sometimes it makes sense to think in
polar coordinates but then other times
you might want to switch it into back
into Cartesian coordinates when you're
actually drawing the shape so in this
scenario theta allows us to control the
sort of the direction in which we want
to place the place to point and the
radius allows us to control how far away
we want that point to be from the origin
of our of our 2d canvas so why am I
telling you about this well when we're
dealing with the regular polygons these
come in really handy regular polygons
are our polygons that are sort of
symmetrical where each side is the same
same length and they have this special
property and that property is that first
of all you can locate all of the
vertices of that polygon honest
next if you were to slice up that
polygon into triangles so just simply
connect all the opposing points through
diagonals it splits the polygon into
little triangles and each one of those
triangles has the same angle at the
center of this polygon and that's really
important we can calculate that angle by
the formula up there so 360 degree
divided by the number of sides so if I
were if I were to draw an octagon here
with eight sides that angle comes about
that comes out to be 360 divided by
eight which is 45 degrees so following
that we can locate the theta value for
every single vertex where the first one
is at zero degrees second one at 45
degrees third one at ninety degrees and
so on and and that's that's pretty
awesome because if we were using polar
coordinates we have the theta value
already and all we need is our to
actually render out this shape so in
order to render that shape we go back to
our polar coordinate system and we start
calculating the x and y values using the
formula I shared earlier so X is our x
cost of theta and Y is our x sine of
theta so we start with theta as zero for
the first point forty five for the
second 90 then 135 180 and so on and
that way we can locate the vertices of
all these points and actually create the
shape that we're trying to build so next
up let's talk a little bit about
something called parameterization and
and then sort of related to this idea of
geometry that we're creating
parametrizations is this concept where
you take a geometry that you're trying
to create and try to reduce it into some
kind of variables that would allow you
to build out that geometry and
parametrization itself is a generic
concept in computer science but for now
I'm just focusing it on its application
for for creating graphics so in our case
we're building out shapes so if you
think about the variables that we need
to build a shape well we need all the
locations of all the vertices in order
to build out that shape that's that's
one way to parameterize that
shape another way to do pyramid tries
that shape is if you think about it if
you have a number of sides we can figure
out what the angles are for each one of
those vertices so the only other thing
that we need to build out that shape is
just the radius so we've reduced those
six vertices down to just two variables
all we need is a number of sides and the
radius in order to build out the shape
so that allows us to do something like
this where we have we have our little
demo that's rendering the shape and I
can connect it to a slider that changes
the number of sides and that's what
drives the shape that we're rendering
out and then the radius simply controls
how big or small that shape is so now
we're starting to get somewhere right so
we're starting to create geometry
dynamically so how would you go about
doing something like this oh for that
I'm going to walk through a little bit
of code for a polygon generator and the
idea is this function will take two
variables a side count and radius so the
number of sides for the polygon that
you're generating and the size of that
polygon and using that it's going to
generate all the it's going to generate
all the vertices needed to render out
that shape so the first thing that
happens inside this inside this function
is it calculates the angle so 360
divided by the number of sides then we
create a placeholder list for all the
vertices that we need to generate for
this shape and to do that I have a
little one-line JavaScript function here
that accepts a count value and what it
does is it generates a list so if you
give it a count of five it will generate
a list of 0 1 2 3 4 5 and return that to
you and then next step what we do is we
iterate over this list the placeholder
list that we generated and then we go
through and generate each vertex one by
one and to generate that vertex we need
to calculate two things we need to
calculate theta and R well R is simply
the radius that we passed into this
function theta on the other hand is
angle times the index of the vortex that
we're trying to calculate so if you
think about
go back to that circle image that I
showed first points it says zero degree
second one at 45 then 90 so essentially
it's just multiples of that angle that
we calculated right 45 degrees and
that's what's happening here the only
thing to keep in mind here is when
you're working with graphics regardless
of what kind of technology you're
working with you generally need to
specify angles in radians instead of
degrees and I personally find easier to
reason about angles and degrees but then
have to convert it into radians in order
to use it to pass it on to whatever is
rendering things and to do that again I
have a little one line function here
that converts the angle from degrees to
radians and to do that all it does is
multiplies the angle by PI and divided
by 180 so using this function were able
to to generate all sorts of polygons
that are regular polygons based on the
side count and the radius that we pass
in so let's see another application of
this so this is an animation that was
originally created by Chris Gannon he
does some truly fantastic work and in
his animation he built it out like
something like this to begin with
where it was a hexagon that had this
really beautiful light diffusion
animation happening to it so what I did
here was take his original animation and
which had the hard-coded hexagon paths
place inside it and replaced it with the
polygon generator so now instead of that
shape being hard-coded that shape could
now be driven dynamically through events
so in this case I linked up that polygon
generator to the sliders again so the
number of sides allows us to change the
shape of the object that's being
animated and the radius again allows us
to control how big or small that object
is so that's pretty cool right we're
building out an animation we're building
our geometry dynamically and then we're
attaching it to animation which can be
morphed in real time to you
so let's go back to that that James
illustration that I showed you how do we
apply a parametrizations it so if you
look closely this one's a little bit
trickier right it's not just that one
shape that you're building out each of
these objects has that one outer shape
but then that shape same shape repeats
on the inside which is slightly smaller
and then there are phases that connect
each one of those inside and outer
shapes so how do you go about doing
something like this well once again we
can leverage that idea of
parametrizations and we don't need to
provide any more variables because if
you look closely the outer shape can be
driven by r and theta still the inner
shape is slightly smaller so we can
choose to make that ratio dynamic and
that would be the extra variable but you
can also hard-code that so in my case i
hard-coded that to be just simply half
of the radius that you're passing in so
we can calculate that inner shape using
r over two instead of the full r and we
calculate the the points same way as
before so x is r cos theta y is r sine
theta and for the inner shape x is r
over two cos theta and y is r over two
sine theta
but then what about the face is how do
we how do we build these faces that
connect the inside and the outside well
if you think about it the faces are
simply made up of vertices of the inside
and the outside so all we need to do is
go and find the coordinates for the you
know sort of the similar sides for both
those shapes so we picked the first side
for the outer shape the first side for
the inner shape take their four points
and connect them together to form the
form from the face so I used exactly
this concept to convert that original
illustration into something a little bit
more dynamic and reactive so this is
built with SVG and react and the idea
here is that I constructed the geometry
dynamically using that polygon generator
again and then wired up the mouse
pointer to to calculate the direction of
the light so dynamically now as the user
moves the mouse pointer on the screen
those gems are lit up differently in
different context
so so definitely it's not as elaborate
lighting as the the original
illustration but it's starting to get
there where you can you can do sort of
interesting stuff where now you can
imagine that some kind of interaction
from the user is driving these
animations live instead of it being
pre-rendered and Static at all times and
of course we can use that same idea of
parametrizations to build our patterns
instead so previously when we were using
polar coordinates we were using it to
find to locate the vertices of a for
geometry and then connect them together
to form a shape but we can use exactly
that same same idea to construct
patterns so so in this case you'll
notice that instead of connecting these
points together to make a shape we're
actually connecting these points
together too and we're simply placing
dots at every single one of those
locations so how do we do this well
similar to before we start by creating
you know we can sort of create that
split that pattern up into multiple
circles and each circle is one layer of
that animation and now that angle
between the different dots it's similar
to the regular polygons before to
calculate that angle we simply decide
how many dots that we want to place on
that circle 360 divided by that those
number of dots will give us the angle
and then we use that angle to locate
every single dot we're placing onto this
page the only difference now is instead
of just being one circle we have many
different layers and each layer has a
different radius so for the innermost
radii innermost circle we use our one to
calculate the X and y values for the
next one we'd use our two and so on and
that that allows us to construct really
elaborate patterns like this and then we
simply animate them to actually do
something like this so speaking of that
animation let's talk a little bit about
waves and oscillations starting with the
simple sine wave you've probably seen
this many many times and most people see
it and ignore it and move on to
something more flashy and more cool but
the nice thing is the sine wave is
actually
extremely powerful it allows us to do
some really really interesting work and
a sine wave has this quality where you
if you changed if you iterate the angle
from 0 to 360 degrees it forms that
wave-like pattern right where it goes
from 0 to 1 down to minus 1 and in back
to 0 but the interesting thing is you
don't need to stop that angle at 360
degrees you can keep going and that
pattern will keep on repeating so you
get this amazing oscillation behavior
without having to worry about do I need
to reset this angle now or do I need to
go to a specific angle you can just keep
looping over it and keep adding values
to it and you get the same motion every
time and the cosine wave is it's
basically the same thing as sine wave
but there's a slight offset to it so
technically you can use them
interchangeably when you're generating
wave-like motion so for now I'm just
going to be focusing on on the sine wave
itself so we can use this sine wave to
create amazing animations like this so
this is this is an animation by Dave
white where he's using the sine wave to
drive the the hexagon pattern up and
down and and basically morphing that
entire geometry and you've probably
heard Dave why he also goes by the name
bees and bombs and a lot of his work
tends to use the used sine waves so here
you'll notice that there's quite a few
examples up top he's using the sine wave
to control the size of blocks so they
increase in decrease in height it's he's
using the sine wave to try to control
the radius of those dots in the hexagon
to create that nice wave-like pattern to
move those blocks around in X or Y
direction or to move the points around
radially or even to just completely
morph the shape of a shape of an object
so it's a really powerful concept just
by using that one simple humble sine
wave you can do some amazing work so how
do you go about leveraging this well
let's start by looking at how you would
use the sine wave in general in an
animation loop so we start by declaring
the initial value of theta that's going
to be driving the entire sine wave so 0
sounds like a good place to start and
then we create our animation loop
so in this animation loop we're simply
going to be iterating theta so we don't
need to worry about stopping at a
particular point or resetting because
sine is a repeating pattern so we simply
add a fun add a line of code there that
says theta equals theta plus some static
value and that static value really
defines how fast or slow you want your
animation to move and all of these
values are in radians so I picked 0.15
that seems like a decent decent speed
for now but if you're changing that rate
you can change it to make your animation
faster or slower or or even change it
over time to get to get like an easing
effect and then we simply calculate the
current value of that sine wave on every
single animation loop so we can
calculate X as sine of theta and then on
every draw loop we use that value to to
run some kind of animation so for the
first example we can use that sine
animation to do Drive translation or
motion in one or two directions so in
this case we're moving that we're
oscillating that red ball across the
screen and the way we do that is we have
that ball has a starting point and all
we want to do is animate it around that
starting point so it's oscillating with
an amplitude so in our animation loop we
calculate the current X position as the
current that the starting point so X
start Plus the amplitude we want it to
ask to oscillate by so in in my case I
picked 300 as a value times the sine
wave that you're generating and that's
going to move this X this X position of
this ball from at the leftmost would be
X minus 300 at the rightmost would be X
plus 300 and that's what produces this
horizontal oscillation motion we can
apply that exact same idea for scaling
so in this case our amplitude of scaling
is I pick this one and then we multiply
that by the sine wave that we're
generating and then we add it to this
the starting point of the scale so in
this case the starting scale is 1 and
then we're also oscillating by 1 so
you'll notice that it goes all the way
down to 0 then it comes back
to its max its normal size and then goes
back down to zero and of course by by
changing that amplitude in this case
that I have one you can change that
animation over time dynamically
responding to different events or
responding to user interaction and
finally we can also use this to drive
rotation so in this case we're trying to
rotate the the red ball around the black
dot that's in the center of the screen
there so to do that now we need to
calculate both x and y values for that
ball so X in this case is the x
coordinate of the origin that's the
black spot black ball in the middle plus
the distance and that's the distance
between the black dot in the middle and
the red ball that's rotating x cost of
theta and this is the only time where
sign-in cost will matter because we're
dealing with polar coordinates again so
the x value always has to be in terms of
costs whereas the Y value has to be in
terms of sine and again and then that
allows us to calculate the x and y
coordinates to create animations like
this so let's let's see some real-world
examples of this so this is a piece that
I found on code pen it's a little rocket
that's rotating around the moon so in
this scenario the origin is the center
of the moon the distance is the distance
between the center of the moon and the
center of the rocket and then we're
simply iterating theta over time to
generate this rotational motion around
the moon so pretty cool stuff we can
also use it to do something a little bit
more complex so going back to some of
daylight's work this this animation is
called Schwimmer and you'll notice that
it's constructed out of a lot of
different points again so in this
scenario we're using parametrizations
but instead of placing it using polar
coordinates going back to the Cartesian
coordinate system to generate that
diamond pattern and then animating each
one of those points that you see in that
pattern and if you'll notice closely the
center row vertically all the dots in
the center row simply move up
or tickly and that's the only animation
that roll next to it on the right hand
side the dots are moving oscillating up
and down but there's also a slight
horizontal oscillation to them and as we
move further away from that Center that
oscillation increases more and more so
all of these dots are oscillating but
not at the same rate there's a slight
difference to every one of them so
that's the last part of it so so you're
using sine sine waves to create these
animations but instead of moving
everything at the same rate or at the
same time just by offsetting them you
can create really beautiful patterns and
the way you do that is something like
this where so we start off with a ball
that's oscillating up and down on the
canvas so in this case we started off
with theta as 0 and then we increment
theta by 0.1 on every single animation
loop then we add a second ball but in
this case instead of starting at theta
as zero
we started at 0.4 and then we add a
third one that started at 0.8 and a
fourth one and a full row of them and
then the second row and another layer
and in each time we simply offset the
starting point that allows us to create
this really beautiful wave-like pattern
and by layering a lot of them we get
this really interesting interesting
motion or they go out of sync and they
keep moving around and then at some
point they come together and they
synchronize for just a moment and then
they go apart go apart again so that's
what that's one way to generate those
offset patterns the other way to
generate those offset patterns is to use
different amplitudes so instead of
oscillating all of them at the same
amplitude so oscillating them all at 300
pixels or something you can choose a
different value for each one of them and
that will give a different kind of
effect and that that's what's happening
here so instead of oscillating each dot
at the same time the horizontal motion
there's a different amplitude for
depending on which row that dot belongs
in oh let's go let's go back to that
rocket example once more so in this
example you'll notice that the rocket is
moving on its own but it's also react
I can actually drag the rocket with my
mouse cursor rotated men manually or
even just like toss it and there's a
little bit of momentum to it so how do
you do that how does it know that when
your mouse cursor is moving around the
page where that rocket needs to be what
angle is it going to be at in that
rotation so in order to do that we need
to talk about yet another mathematical
concept and this one's known as solving
triangles so solving triangles is this
idea where you have a triangle and you
know something about it you know one
angle you know maybe you know a couple
of things or you know one side or a
couple of sides or a mixture of like one
angle in one side and you're trying to
find all the other missing sides or the
missing angles so for now I'm going to
focus on a simplified case of this which
I tend to encounter a lot while making
animations and that's the right angle
triangle so since it's a right angle
triangle it has a few properties one
angle we know is 90 degrees and then
there are a couple of other angles which
we know have to be less than 90 degrees
and they should add up to 90 degrees and
then it has three sides the opposite the
adjacent adjacent which is the base of
the triangle and then the hypotenuse so
once we know this we can start talking
about how would we go about solving this
triangle so we often find ourselves in
these scenarios where okay I know this
is a right angle triangle I maybe know
two of the sides and I need to figure
out what the angle is for the between
the hypotenuse and the base or one of
the other angles or I might know that
angle and one of the sides and I need to
figure out the third side so how do we
do that well for that we need to go back
to high school for a bit you might
remember this mnemonic device of silca
Toa well that's exactly what we're going
to use here to to figure out those
angles or the missing information so we
have these three formulas which you tend
to use quite a lot to solve triangles so
sine of theta is over H cos of theta is
over H and tan of theta is over a so if
I wanted to figure out what that angle
theta is I can use that last formula of
ten of theta is over a and calculate
theta as our tangent of over a so our
tangent is simply in inverse of 10 so if
you move 10 from the left hand side of
the equation to the right hand side it
turns into our tangent so let's see this
in action this is a demo from the p5.js
examples and it's a little example of
eye tracking or sort of a simplified
version of eye tracking so you'll notice
that these three eyes sort of track the
mouse cursor which is the purple dot and
they try to always look at that mouse
cursor if you look at a little bit
closer you'll notice that the pupil of
the eye the the black part is simply
rotating about the center of the eye so
it's a very similar setup to that rocket
example except instead of rotating
outside the moon is rotating inside the
eye so as I move the cursor around the
page what I need to do is figure out the
angle of rotation for that particular
circle and the way I do that is by
solving triangles so you might be asking
wait what triangle what are we solving
here so let me enable some debugging
here so you'll notice that if we connect
the purple dot which is the mouse cursor
and the blue dot which is the center of
the eye it actually forms a right hand
right right angled triangle and since we
know the location of the center of the
eye and we know the location of the
mouse cursor we can actually we actually
know the the base of the triangle and we
know the height of the triangle so we
can use those two values and put it into
our arctangent formula and calculate
that angle that the eye needs to be so
in this demo what's happening is we're
solving three triangles at the same time
one for one for each eye and as the
mouse cursor moves around the page it's
simply figuring out the angle and
rotating the black circle by that value
and this is sort of a more elaborate
version of that eye-tracking this one
was built by Hakeem al khattab for the
net 404 just therefore for error page
and along with that are tracking idea it
has a few more things happening here so
the eyes are blinking and you can add
more layers of animation to that initial
reactivity that you're adding that
you're creating let's look at another
example of solving triangles so in this
case this is a little animation I made a
few years ago where I'm trying to
replicate a very cartoony lighting
system where you can see the the yellow
circle acts as the source of light and
based on how close or far away I'm from
the triangle that that controls this
glossy disc lossy shine that you can see
on the page there so again how am I
using solving problem solving triangles
here let's go to the debug version of
this so in this case you'll notice that
we know the location of the center of
the triangle we know the location of the
source of light and what we really need
to figure out is the two points that
make up that glass and there's one other
variable that we actually know in this
case we know the spread of the light and
spread of light in this case is a
triangle that we're using here and in
this case that spread of light is
controlled by the distance between the
the source of the light and the center
of the triangle so the further away I am
from the triangle the wider that
triangle gets and the closer I go to it
the narrower that triangle gets so in
this case I actually know the angle of
that triangle at all times and and then
finally we also know the distance from
the center of the triangle to where that
glass is being drawn that's the the take
green line that you see there so since
we know that one distance we know the
angle we can actually calculate the
location where those Wordie seas are
going to be placed and that allows us to
build figure out how long that glass
needs to be and render it out as a as a
stroke
one more example of solving triangles so
this one is from the paper J's
documentation site they have an example
of metal balls normally metal balls are
built using using shaders and this is a
slightly different version of metal
balls where instead of using shaders
it's built using canvas and just
connecting shapes together so in this
case what you'll notice is the meta
balls are made up of two circles the the
little circle and then the big circle
that I can move around with my mouse
cursor and then if the two circles come
close enough there's a connector that
come that becomes between the two of
them and that's where we're using the
idea of solving triangles so for this
particular one I have debugging enabled
so you'll notice that as I move the
circle close enough the connector shows
up and then the connector is connecting
two points on each of the circles and
those two points have handles that
decide how narrow or wide that connector
needs to be so in this scenario what we
need to do is figure out that angle of
that that connector that's Ari they have
that handle and the way we can do that
is we know the radius of the circles we
know the point at which that that handle
is going to be generated so again it
form forms a triangle and we can use
that to calculate the angle of that
handle and then generate this connector
so as I go closer or further away you
can see the connector moving wide or
coming closer and of course this concept
is used a lot in in sort of physics
applications so for game development so
here I have a link to a blog post by
Rachel Smith which covers the idea of
using solving triangles to to actually
build out leavers so sort of similar
idea to what certain games like Angry
Birds or you know any of any of those
kinds of games tend to use so if you if
kind of interested in this idea I would
recommend highly recommend reading that
blog post to get a lot more detail about
how to solve triangles and I'll share a
link to that in my slides after the talk
and finally I wanted to talk a little
bit about easing so if you've ever done
CSS animations you're probably dealt
with some kind of easing right when we
create our animation we specify what
kind of easing we want but it's linear
or a sine wave or cubic or quadratic all
kinds of stuff right so CSS has a lot of
easing predefined and we can simply
select which one we want to apply and
each one of those easing that we choose
is known as an easing function so an
easing function is something that drives
the relationship between time and the
progress of that animation and a lot of
those functions are predefined except a
cubic Bezier one that's something that
we can actually configure to our liking
even in CSS so a cubic Bezier easing is
essentially a curve of this sort and
usually you need four four variables to
generate that curve one the start value
the end value and then the location of
the two handles however in CSS that
start value is always set to be zero
zero the end value is always set to be
one one so the only thing we need to
provide to generate this curve is the
location of the two handles and that's
what those four numbers are so if you've
ever written a CSS animation with cubic
material all it by four numbers those
are the locations of those two handles
so the first one is the x coordinate of
the first handle second one is the y
coordinate of the first handle and then
the last two are the X and the y
coordinate of the second handle so we
can use this to generate more customized
curves that define the easing that we
want to use and there's many tools out
there if you just search for cubic
Bezier you'll find hundreds of tools out
there that allow you to generate those
curves but when you're working with
JavaScript animation libraries you can
go one step further you can actually
build your own easing function and one
of the most popular ways to do this is
on the web especially is to use
something called Penner's equations in
Penner's equations are a certain type of
equations
take four variables and then construct
how how your animation is going to
progress so how is it going to go from
the starting point to the end point and
the four variables that you need that
that equation receives is starting with
the current time
so as you're tweeting from start to end
what is the current time in your
animation loop and this can be in any
unit as you as you want it could be in
seconds in milliseconds in frame counts
as long as you're using the same unit
throughout your throughout your app
throughout your animation
the second argument that's passed in is
the start value so this is the start
value of the property that you're
animating the third is Delta which is
the change between the start value and
the end value of the enemy of the
property that you're animating and then
finally the duration the total duration
of the animation or the tween or the
transition that you're generating and
then the body of the function usually
consists of something like this where
you have the start value plus the delta
times some kind of multiplier and that
multiplier usually comes from a
transform so that transform kind of
decides how your animation is going to
behave whether it's going to have a
linear ease if it's going to have a
bounce ease or some kind of really crazy
East that you're creating so let's look
at an example of an easing that's
generated using the Penner's equations
so this is something I found from
Potocki who's a jiff I really talented
Jeff animator and on his blog he shared
this function that he uses quite often
for to generate easing so down here
you'll notice is the the actual pen or
equation and that start value plus some
kind of multiplier that we're generating
and then the multiplied by Delta so that
transform function is really the only
one we mostly need to care about so in
this case this is the transform function
that's being defined so there's a lot of
math going on here and it takes a while
to get your head around that and
understand exactly what's happening here
but the nice thing about here about this
is you don't need to worry about it you
can just go ahead and
start using it because the only thing
that you need to care about is that
first line of code the G equals six by
modifying that value of G you can
generate all kinds of and all kinds of
easing so it's a really nice formula
that allows you to generate different
kinds of easing x' just by modifying
that one value here's another example of
bounce easing so this is something from
mat deloria's eases library so generally
if you go and look at code for a bounce
transition you'll notice that there's a
lot of code there there's like four or
five lines of code that decide what kind
of that animation what that function
needs to be to generate that easing but
this is a much more stripped-down
simplified version of that so in this
case the nice thing is you'll notice
this number here at 13 that constant is
the only thing that drives the
springiness of this bounce easing so but
by increasing or decreasing that value
you can control whether this is going to
be a really really stiff straight spring
so you know it bounces very slightly and
stops right away or it's going to be a
really really flexible spring where it
wobbles around many times before coming
to a stop so again it's really you don't
need to understand the full math here
but just by knowing what one number you
can change in order to generate
different eases allows you to construct
really interesting behaviors and once
you understand this idea of what a
Penner equation is and what that
transform part is you can start using it
to construct your own custom easing
functions
so most JavaScript animation libraries
will allow you to define that so you
don't need to worry about constructing
the full pen or equation the only part
you need to worry about creating is the
actual transform itself so the one that
depends on the current time so this is
an example of how you would define a
custom easing for anime Jas which is a
fairly popular JavaScript animation
library so you can replace this with the
body of this function with any of the
previous two examples that I showed and
and use those custom easing patterns in
your own when you're working with
animators and that allows you to make
interesting things
like this demo that I created were on
every click all of those little layers
of the Box animate with a different
spring level so in this case I'm
constructing five or different five or
six different kinds of spring easing and
then layering them on top of each other
to create this staggered effect where
each box sort of bounces at a different
rate and that's about it
thank you for coming out